so Angela
hi Eddie so funny little things above
as-salaamu alayka were admitted right we
were a care to brothers and sisters
welcome to this episode of the matter of
Xena how to protect to yours how to
protect yourself from dinner and not
fall into it obviously before I start I
want to praise Allah so Allah the most
merciful the most just all praises and
glory belong to him all the work that we
do it we do with this permission so I
won't start off like that now brothers
and sisters the fact that you have
clicked on this video shows that you
either maybe I'm not jumping to
assumptions now you either want to stop
committing zina or maybe you're on the
verge of coming zina or maybe you just
clicked it just to watch it for the sake
of it but for those who are on the verge
or who are in the act of zina
I've got good news for you because the
fact that you clicked on this link shows
that you have in mind in your heart that
you hate the sin and you want to stop it
now the fact that you hate it and the
fact that you want to stop it the two
principles are there of repentance what
do I mean by this to repent of a sin
whatever it may be you first have to
stop the sin number two you need to hate
the sin number three you do not go back
to the sin and obviously as we know is
good to pray 2 rakaats from nur priya
and make repentance and Tolbert Oliphant
allah' so the fact that you've clicked
on this video shows that you do not like
the sin that you're doing and you really
want to stop it now those litt objects
is that we have with this video is for
you to complete the repentance and not
go back to that sin and insha'Allah
after this video you can pray 2 rakaats
from na and inshallah will the finish of
Allah you will not go back to that sin
now brothers and sisters as you guys
know we live in a society where it's
sexualized it is everywhere we go
everywhere we look it's sexualized this
is the society that we live in
unfortunately but now for you guys and
this is a message for both genders but
specifically for the brothers now I
understand where you guys are coming
from now brothers and sisters many at
times if somebody has hinted that your
own relationship with your girlfriend
boyfriend whatever it is they will come
and say to you is haram is haram now me
personally I don't agree with this
concept why what do I mean by this if
somebody comes and says to you
is Haram Haram the fact is this if you
don't have a connection with your Lord
if you don't understand how eat if you
don't understand the mercy of your Lord
the matters of Jannah paradise and
Hellfire
if you don't understand this the word
Haram would not hit your head it
wouldn't get into your system because
you're just gonna think Haram oh it's
not only allowed but the moment you have
the connection with your node and you
understand that small sin or that big
sin that you do that you commit it's not
about the sin of being a big or small
it's the one is the almighty that you're
sinning against once you have that
connection with Allah then you will
understand the words of her arm Allah
etc in detail now now as we know our
mother I shall run the along and said if
the Quran came down as Haram and halal
nobody the sahabas would never accept
the Quran and follow the regulations so
what we understand by this is that it's
the connection that we have with
Almighty another third part is that you
don't want to go back to the sin now
what you need to understand this the
Shaitaan is going to be on your case and
others wrote Allah says in the Quran and
the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu was
telling them that the biggest fitna for
men is a female it is hard it's gonna be
madness it's gonna be crazy for you guys
but we need to understand is this the
moment you repent and tries not to go
back even if you end up falling for the
sin again do not ever doubt the mercy of
your Lord do you know everything you
know what it's not gonna happen don't
because me personally through the
friends that I know before they have had
gradual steps and even though they've
gone back to committing the sin they've
had a moment where they said enough is
enough
now guys the first step that we need to
take is this we don't want to go back to
us we don't want to go there and
knowledge it in your head
programming you don't want to go back to
that sin now I lost want Allah says in
the Quran we do not change a nation or
an individual unless they want to change
their souls so you need to put in the
actions and the effort that you want to
do it then you put your trust in Allah
and another narration of this is though
of the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu was
send him where a man didn't tie his camo
and he was walking off so the rest so
rasulullah asked him said why didn't you
tell your camel
he said o rasulallah because i put my
trust in Allah he said tie your camel
first then put your trust in Allah
then or simultaneously so we need to
understand that they go hand to hand
make water lands they all look your Lord
your Lord is there for you always so you
need to understand that you need to make
dua to him and say Allah help me I won't
stop this sin once you're clueless this
the effort comes in now how does the
effort work in I have spoken to many
brothers that I know from back in the
days and they would say to me a key I
will cry when I'm coming zina I don't
want to do it I hate it straight after I
do I start to cry this shows that
there's a man in the individuals heart
even though he's committing the sin he
hates it he doesn't want to do it but he
can't help himself now we need to
understand we we as as Alice wanted says
in the Quran that the biggest fitna and
the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu Selim
citizen hadith that the biggest fitna
for a man is female we acknowledge that
and the society that we live in doesn't
make it easy for us but now we need to
understand that what can we do to erase
that
now these robbers the obstruction before
have said to me that when they remove
all these images all these new things
the people that they follow in their
social media Facebook Twitter Instagram
wherever it may be they said that one of
the things that was really effective is
decide to unfollow delete pictures stop
talking to certain individuals because
the moment you do this you are taking
out all this advertisement I call
advertiser and I'm gonna tell you why
you are taking out all these advertisers
who are popping up in your screen every
now and then and reminding you back of
your desires or those individuals that
you was with in the past
now that is similar to McDonald's
McDonald's is a multi-billionaire
company but they still advertise why let
me tell you why because they want to
remind you that filler of fish to keep
it halal that you like is still there
and can be served now how does this work
if you haven't had let's say a thinner
fish burger from McDonald's for two
three months you've took you said you
know what I don't want that anymore okay
now what are you doing is the
remembrance of that anything to do with
it you're blanking it you know it's that
you learned it's that except when you go
from McDonald's you're lower in your
case now I want to tell you guys how
that works because when you go to your
social media and blog
Oh delete numbers don't see those
individuals who will remind you of your
past anything to do with Zener that's
gonna get your desires to urge now the
fact that you don't do that and when
you're out in the street out and about
and you're no well in your case one lie
these brothers were telling me this was
the main factor that helped me to
overcome sin up with the permission of
Allah so now this comes into the part of
your asking Allah for help and you're
putting in the work and with the
permission of Allah so Allah what Allah
he brothers and sisters try it today
Twitter Instagram Facebook delete I'll
follow
anything that nude anything that's doing
nude or girls whatever it is delete it
take it off if you are not reminded of
it like I said with McDonald's once they
start advertising it once you haven't
had that for three months that fill it a
fish burger and and you see on the TV
you're gonna be a ah do you get what I'm
trying to see you're gonna be reminded
you don't gonna be like oh man do you if
you get what I'm trying to say you're
gonna go on want to buy it
so this is how advertisement works so
what you're gonna do is cut it out now
let's move on okay now the hope where
does it come in making a lot now nobody
seems to you guys okay live away from
the horror on the Zener okay and just
stay like that you know just be like a
nun you know just you know better get
married low Anna has given you the
highlight option you get married you can
fast as we know the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu wasallam said you can fast if
you're going through these urges try
fasting multi abundance is one life
there is nothing but these brothers have
talked to before the beauty of living
that Haram lifestyle behind and moving
on and doing in a halal way getting
married what why he by Allah I'm telling
you guys Allah doing it the halal option
and marrying that person you like and
striving there is nothing better or
nothing that can replace that so pursued
the way of marriage in the halal means
now now guys the next step that we want
to do is we want to hate this thing
even more so we don't go back to it now
brothers I really want to talk to you
guys here let's go and take a little
walk down memory lane
now now guys I want you guys to imagine
with me now you are going out there and
committing this act with other people's
sisters other people's daughters now my
dear brothers and sisters can you
imagine if the act that you're doing
somebody did that to your sister can you
imagine the act that you're doing
somebody did that to your daughter or
your mother now I want you guys to
really reflect upon this because this is
really important no matter how much you
see and justify to yourself and say oh
but she's a ho or she's this she's that
I don't care so imagine it's in your
head every time you take a step to go
ahead and do this act you need to think
to yourself and say hold on a second
would I want that for my sister so
another of the sisters with acknowledged
the matter of halal and Haram making a
connection with your Lord the basic
steps as brothers that we can take to
prevent this and what we can do to avoid
this so brothers and sisters hope you
guys have benefited inshallah if you
have share it with your friends and
inshallah they will benefit and like I
said guys if you fall into this sin
again go back to the same process
because Allah says in the Quran all my
servants are and rest against themselves
do you not ever display the mercy of
your Lord your Lord is always there no
matter if you go back turn back to your
Lord benefited may Allah's mercy in
blessings be upon you all so brothers
and sisters thank you for watching me I
was mercy and blessings be upon you or
me I was font Allah grant every single
one of you guys Jannah at the end of the
video before you turn off watch the
videos at the end very beneficial videos
if you know her own relations you want
to come off etc etc watch it take care
good bye
you